Speaker 1: Hey, this voicemail I have to
play for you today is really emblematic of
the sort of arrogance that we now see among
many on the right. This is a caller named
Juan who used to call in and say he was the
anti-intellectual. Now he just says it's one.
And it turns out Juan realized he knows
more than his doctors. This is without
a shred of irony. Guys, take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, it's me again, Juan. Right.
Health care is a scam. Anecdotally, most of the
doctors that I've had to deal with are ignorant,
and they've had to correct them several times.
Speaker 1: So anecdotally, and maybe you're
dealing with the wrong doctors one
Speaker 6: and at the end of my
interaction with them. They've
ended up agreeing with me.
Oh, they have no clue. They have a set of
knowledge and ideas and in their minds.
That they learned in school and college and
university. Right. But there's a lot of research.
That is a lot more up to date than what they think
Speaker 1: now, of course, any good doctor is
staying up to date on the research, of course. And
in my experience, when I mentioned to a doctor,
Hey, you know, I recently read about X, whether
it's in dermatology or whatever they say, Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm familiar with that. So the
idea that doctors know less than one because they
go based on what they learned in medical school
five, 10, 20, 30 years ago, but Kwan is doing
internet research. This is this is the height of
the type of arrogance that got us the ivermectin
stuff, nebulizer and hydrogen peroxide, et cetera.
Speaker 6: I think health care needs to be
abolished. Well, and totally
built from the ground up.
Speaker 1: So anyway, listen, guys, we're up
against some pretty serious stuff and with not
a shred of irony, confidently one saying the
fact that he looked stuff up on the internet.
And knew more than his doctors, I guess, is
evidence that the medical field is bad, I mean,
it's it's it's crazy. It's really, really
crazy. And this is what we're up against.
We've got a great bonus show for you today. Joe
Biden is facing a squeeze on defense spending from
the left and from the right. It's very interesting
politically what's going on? Tennessee is trying
to find a loophole in order to be able to ban
same sex marriage. The problem is they might
legalize child brides in so doing, it's bonkers
what's going on there? And we'll talk about Alex
Jones facing jail time at this point. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Sign up at Join Pacman dot com to get instant
access. Go to David Pakman dot com slash free
membership to request a free membership. And
anybody who wants can gift memberships to others
by checking that this is a gift box when signing
up at join at CNNMoney.com. I will see you then.